[Music]
guys i've got a star talk sports edition
explainer
this one
about golf lip outs in golf gary i think
we're going to have to
muzzle chuck for this i don't know if
he's okay he's he's highly golf
opinionated and i don't know i just
i'm not telling what he's going to say
i'll let you know
the truth that's it
i don't get the feeling chuck's
clubhouse friendly it's true
oh wait why are we playing at augusta
now what is that
what is going on
all right let's get back to lip outs
people okay you know i
i
see golf i'm not a golf player
you know i just always imagine the
conversation between a golfer and a
baseball player right
and just how that would go by so the
baseball player says
uh
so
uh you want complete silence when you
hit the ball i say yeah we need silence
and they say well how fast is the ball
moving
not at all it's stationary well where is
it oh it's right between my feet
and so and so you need silence yeah that
takes concentration well how about you
oh well our ball is moving 90 miles an
hour
thrown by someone who doesn't want me to
hit it it's just like being booed while
all your wild 50 000 people are
screaming at you but what we all know is
that certain
golf
typically a putt but any it can happen
on any
on any um
shot the ball will hit the rim of the
cup
and then spiral around and pop out
frustrating for the golfer because
that's a lost uh shot right there it's a
stroke off yeah
it's just a strawberry and right yeah
that's a lot of lots of history okay
yeah thank you we'll go withdraw
shall we
drop shot but so it's
uh
so what's interesting about it is it can
happen almost no matter how far away you
are from the cup
i've there's some they're good videos of
compilations of lip outs where some guy
was like a couple of feet away and he
taps it in but it lips out
and then everyone says oh and then he
just goes around a little cocky said
you're going in this time bop lips out
again and so he lost two strokes when
the ball was was within two feet of the
cup yeah i think they saw that you suck
pretty sure that's the golfing turn
that's the official the official golfing
turn see i mean if anyone's watched
caddyshack the movie they know it's a
gopher in the hole that's pushing the
ball
the gopher i forgot about the gopher
the gophers at fault for all of it yes
so so here's what's going on you
you think you're hitting the ball
straight and you are and so the ball has
has what we call linear momentum
so it's momentum in the direction it's
headed yeah
however
if you do not hit the ball exactly
towards the center of the cup
and it sees the rim of the cup
it's like you reaching out to like a
maypole as you're trying to run by it
grabbing it and what happens to you oh
you get to swing around you swing around
so all of a sudden your linear momentum
okay
what you think is purely linear momentum
also manifests as angular momentum
around the pole
okay so that happens you reach out and
grab so when the
ball sees the depression in the cup
that's effectively falling towards the
middle of the cup and so there's angular
momentum there that is getting picked up
as it goes around the center and
depending on how fast the ball is moving
and how much on the lip it was
it'll either
swivel and go in or swivel and pop out
again
and so the only way to avoid this on
every single shot is hit it directly to
the center of the cup
that's all to the center of the cup and
it drops in does it matter on how is
there a critical mass of the ball that
must be below the lip of the card oh
very good point so so i'd have to do a
calculation on this but i would say if
you got half the mass
of the ball below the lip
that it's going in yeah uh that's
and
because it's very it's it's very hard
to to all of a sudden have a force
vector pointing upwards while this is
happening by the way unless the ball is
spinning
okay depending on which way the ball is
spinning if it's spinning it can
actually crawl out if that's the
direction the spin is going that happens
in basketball where you see the ball
ring around well so basketball lip outs
are every third shot right i mean when
you think about it it rings around and
then it comes it gets thrown out it's
actually in the hole
you know it's in the cylinder well i
haven't seen it find me one where it's
half already oh oh god yeah i don't
think it oh come on now yes
i don't think more than half but
definitely it's in the cylinder yeah up
to half
and depending on the spin the the the
internal angular momentum the ball had
by your shot that'll affect what it's
going to do as it kisses the rim yes all
right and so some shooters will give a
backspin right when they hit the back of
the rim so then the spin takes it in
with that much more vigor but if you if
you have different spins and you hit the
rim in the wrong way it's going to spin
in a way you don't want you're not going
to make the shot so the same is true in
golf and in golf you know the spin on
the ball matters right for so many of
those shots particularly ones that are
onto the green you don't want to keep
moving and rolling off the green so so
many of them have backspin the tip
bunker shots neil if you if you found
yourself in a sand trap you've got to
get right underneath the ball flatten
the face of the club and then you impart
the backspin on it so as it doesn't
overrun on a on a fast screen and then
will spin and drop and then
that will be the
uh and golfers are excellent navigators
of subtleties and terrain so that if
you're going to do a backspin you're
going to do it on a on the high side
you're on the high side so then it rolls
back down so you're going to think this
through
well you'll do it even if it goes low
right you especially need it if it goes
low because you don't want it to then
roll off and go into the into the pond
or into the brush so
all i'm saying is that the only way to
avoid it is to send it straight in so
remind me again why why when it it looks
like it's going to go in it rises up
what is
elevating that for it to lip out and not
lip
down
okay so yeah so what you're saying is
it's already partly in the cup
so what's it doing so it has so much
momentum
right the question is how is that
momentum going to manifest okay and so
as it comes so let's say you're going to
lip left to right and out it goes in so
what's actually happening is it's almost
like
the
bank
of the track in nascar oh
okay think about that
if you come to
in fact why don't we talk about
banks and nascar in the next segment
there's a nice
lead into that so so here i am in a car
and if i'm driving too fast
on that bank
okay i can tell you now if you drive 300
miles an hour into a bank
i don't think the rubber in the road is
going to hold you to the bank and it
looks like you should just fall into the
middle you're just going to fall in no
you're going to fly right out headed the
other direction on the other side of the
track okay so we're imparting that
theory into a golf ball as to why it
raises or rises out of
correct correct because when you're in a
car and you're on a bank you feel
this force sort of pushing you outward
right depending on how fast you hit that
bank and
that that that fact that's what helps
keep you on the track provided you don't
take the turn too fast so
so all we're saying here here is that on
that turn if you have enough momentum
then that momentum will continue to
carry
and the fact that the ball is a little
bit in won't matter
because it's it's roll it's it's it's
seeing the because it by the way it's
not in the cup when that happens it's on
the part of the grass that that bends in
yeah it's on the lip yeah it's on a lip
and on that lip it's not a perfect 90
degrees right it's like it's a small
tiny little bang tiny little bank it's a
tiny little bank between the grass and
the turf and where the cup begins and
that's the bank where this thing flies
out on now of course if only we could
get that ball
to do what the car on the bank does
which is fly out
and then explode in a fiery ball of
death
i will watch golf
i will watch golf
that would be amazing
finally
we'll talk to the authorities on that
one
i can't see this taking off on the golf
channel can you
oh i certainly can
[Laughter]
exploding golf oh my god i'm watching
that we've all seen uh uh um
clips of practical jokes where the ball
is something that explodes on it not
explodes dangerously but just pulverizes
on impact we've seen that right you make
a golf ball out of chalk or something
and but you know the person doesn't know
it you're the one who puts the ball on
uh on the ground waiting for them and
then they hit it and then it's just a
puff of smoke
right there
is imminently more entertaining than
actual talk
do you get the worst
that's all i'm saying but it's more
entertaining than what's your golf could
we get whisper commentary though
oh oh that'd be so awesome just like
he's addressing the ball right now
uh it's a beautiful day here at augusta
uh winds around the south southwest i
see the ball is on the t
as he approaches the ball
uh here's the backswing and oh my god it
started what the hell just happened
okay
okay i'm sure chuck's agent if the phone
is ringing off the hook to get chuck to
comment come on
that is
awesome exploding golf so if if any of
our audience are listening or watching
this
and they play golf and they lip out in
the future it's not because you suck
it's just because of science it's
science right and by the way of course
the ball can
can like bounce in and bounce off the
bottom of the cup and bounce out that's
not lipping it yeah but that's that's
whoa now now you just i gotta know now
maybe you know or not
let's say the ball does
pop in like it's bouncing bouncing
bouncy bounces in the cup and back out
bounces back out
is that still considered it touched the
bottom of the cup yes
is that a shot made or do you have to
then complete
put it back in the cup have you sunk
have you sunk that is that technically a
sink or whatever you call it that's yeah
without it yeah because the cup is metal
isn't it so there's every chance but
it's ten yeah ten cups as they say yeah
so if if it falls vertically
then there's a chance
it could participate that's what i'm
saying it could pop back out if it's a
high enough arc on the bounce and it
ends up falling directly into the cup
hitting the bottom and then popping back
out
right is that now a shot maybe it just
needs enough energy to bounce several
even bounce a couple of times we need
officials we need golf officials i'm
suspecting the ball has to still be in
the bottom of the cup when you reach in
there oh see that is cold blooded man
yeah no just become a better golfer
that's all chuck
i put it in the cup how much better can
i be
i mean
you know that's kind of like if the ball
has enough arc where
it falls through the basketball hoop
which is highly unlikely but then
somehow bounces back up through the
basketball you still get the two points
oh
so you're talking about it falls through
the hoop
bounces off the ground it goes back up
through the hoop and you come down two
points as a matter of fact they should
give you six points
but
you still get to keep imagine how high
you would have to be for to get the
rebound to go back up through that that
is that you would get the two points on
that chart you just get three points
right so that's what i'm saying like no
no i know i know the new rule
if it
if it goes backwards through the hoop it
subtracts the points
that's just wrong
[Laughter]
okay so so our our uh crack team of uh
behind-the-scenes researchers has
confirmed that a ball that bounces out
that counts as a stroke
okay
that so
so you don't get the you don't get this
it's not over you still got to play that
ball
correct correct that's terrible
this is why i hate golf
shots
this okay we should rename this reasons
why chuck h dolls
not enough explosions number one there
you go starting with that that's the
michael bay reason not enough explosions
not enough chase scenes yeah right no
chase scenes and if the ball bounces in
the hole which is the whole point of the
game
if i get the ball in the hole if i
actually achieve the objective of the
game which is to put the ball in the
hole if the ball comes back out of the
hole then the objection is uh i i i have
not completed my objective
so
all right so now here's another thing if
you want to if you want to spin on the
ball to help you not get a lip out if
you give a little sort of i don't know
if you can do this with a putter but
surely there's a way you give it a
slight sort of backspin
very slight
okay
so that when it begins to lean into the
cup the backspin takes it down into the
cup right on but if you give it front
spin
which is would normally happen if it's
sort of rolling in a normal way it has
front spin as it goes in but you can you
can disrupt that a little by by
subtracting some of that front spin so
the ball is skidding for part of the way
you can do that all right but if you
give it front spin then that sucker is
just going to want to want to
you know i've seen some lip outs where
it's gone twice around the hole uh
before it came out
so
yeah okay
you got it
you got it so so that's that's lipping
out on the golf course now we've haven't
we done other shows about the the
science of golf clubs and things i think
we have yeah um
we need to do a show called golf sucks
that's not stop stop
guys that'll that's all we have time for
and gary chuck barely behaved on that
one just barely chunks chunk truth to
power
it's truth to power people that's all it
is all right
all right star talk sports edition
explainer
neil degrasse tyson here keep looking
[Music]
you